the clark county school district working
to address the substitute teacher
shortage this week the district
announced an incentive program next week
the focus will be on more hires joe
mohler is live from the school district
headquarters with more information hi
joe
yeah teachers say the substitute
shortage is very real and they say
something needs to be done about it
during the pandemic come next week the
board will look at a few options
we need them especially during covid
as the pandemic continues so does the
substitute teacher shortage at ccsd this
is the most important time for us to
have an adequate sub pool teacher vicki
kreidel says some teachers are not using
their days off due to the shortage
according to a report from the district
the problem is worse now than it was
before the pandemic a teacher just needs
a day
they're ill or whatever
we don't have coverage this week the
district announced a one thousand dollar
incentive for substitutes if they work
44 days between august and october the
district told 8 news now there are 4
thousand subs and the incentives offer
additional compensation as they work to
ensure adequate staffing at schools they
say we have 4 000 substitutes in the
district i don't know where they are
because they're not in our schools this
spotlight will shine on the shortage at
thursday's board meeting two options are
being discussed hiring 1 000 full-time
substitutes or outsourcing substitute
teachers from a third party staffing
company substitute teacher kenosha
wright worries about a staffing company
they bring more stuff in and keep what
we have
you know
it'd be great
says better pay and benefits are the
answer not a stepping company if we
don't have enough bodies to take the sub
jobs now
what makes you think you're going to
have enough people in the sub pool
to fill the need after you start with
the agency
teachers say moving forward the biggest
concern is covet and having to
quarantine they hope they can find some
more subs here in the near future
reporting live at the ccsd headquarters
joe mullen good news now